[音楽]
ん
n
ああああああ
さぁ今日は3つのことについてお話をします
好奇心に素直になること
人と違うことを恐れないこと想定外の事も楽しむこと
この3つです
学生時代私は背が高いせいで日本の恋愛マーケットにマッチしないなぁという気持ちを
抱えていました
でもすいません今ごまかしたんですけれども
背が高いこと以外にも理由があったかと思いますが
要するに全然モテなかったんです
そこで思い立って日本以外の国に結婚相手を探しに行くことにしました
52カ国を回って世界一周をしてたくさんの出会いがありました
最終的には恋人を見つけてその人は日本に来ていたんですけれども
あっけなく振られてしまいました
今は日本人と結婚しています
探しにいった意味がありませんでした
さて子供が3歳になってそろそろまた旅に出たい
12年前に行かなかったいいのに行きたいと思い始めました
2ヶ月前私はワクワクしながら旅立ちました
インドで最も面白かったことは普段はヒマラヤに住んでいる
サドゥーという1000人にあったことです
彼らは基本的に全裸デー
しを象徴する灰を全身につけていって
家を持たず家族も持たず仕事も持たず旅をしながら暮らしています
彼らは出家をする時に死亡届を提出しているので基本的には法的にいないことになって
います
そういう人がインドには500万人もいると言われています
彼らは瞑想をするために大麻を吸います
インド政府は大麻を禁止しているんですけれども彼らに対しては黙認している状態です
まああの存在しないことになってるんで多分たいほどができないんだと思います
あるとき彼らが局部丸出しのところにクルクルクルっと昨日某
巻きつけてその上に仲間を乗せて見せた時は度肝を抜かれました
見てくださいこの後や顔
ジクレーした人になると局部を使って車を引っ張ることもできるらしいです
結構現地のインド人の男性は
顔をしかめながら見ていました
ほかにも数十年ずーっと片手を上げ続けている人とか
数十年誰ともためらっしゃべらないことを徹底している人とかいろんな人がいます
でもかエラーが授業で一番大事にしていることは自由でいること
物理的にも精神的にも縛られないということなんです
これを私たちと勘違いしてました
仙人だから厳しい修行をしている
1細前ライトいうかすごいんだと思って
地味0
a
なんとなくこう苦労してそうな左右にばっかり話しかけたんです
でも彼らの自由っていう本当の意味は
芝親子近づきたいと思って辛いことをしたければしたっていいんです
したくなかったらしなくたっていいんです
おしゃれをしたかったらしたっていいし
持ちたいものがあったら持ったっていいんです
友達と弦見たかったら友達とつるんだっていいんです
それが去る以外の人でも誰も気にしません
tan
属性に戻りたかったら守ることだって ok なのです
これを見て私はあはは人いて固定観念にとらわれていいかなって痛感しました
世界最大の平和集会クンブメーラにも行きました
これはインド中から1億人が集まる頻度教の祭りです
目的は開催場所の川に生えることなんですけれどもこの時の沐浴1回は普段の1000
回分にあたると言われているので彼らはすごく楽しそうに
子供からおじいちゃんおばあちゃんまで
楽しんでいました
この様子を見て私はあ世界は経済じゃなくて信仰心で動いてるんだな
自分は地球上に70億人いるうちのたった一人にしか過ぎなかったんだなっていうこと
を実感しました
私が日本に帰ってきてからよく聞かれる質問が3つあります
一つ目はなーんでインドに行きたかったの
聞いなる方いらっしゃいますか
ありがとうございます
破壊と再生を司るしばしに興味があったからって言うと結構納得してもらえます
私は不幸かの cross fm を始めとして会社の再生という仕事を長く携わって
きたからです
でも本当の理由は違います
ただインドに行ってみたかったから
憧れていたからそれだけなんです
でもこのシンプル極まりない質問はあんまり納得してもらえません
人は好きだとか面白いワクワクするっていう単純な理由ではあんまり納得しないで色々
と理屈をこねたがあります
でも注意しなきゃいけないと思ってます
あんまり理由をつけすぎると本当は自分がないや好きだったのかわからなくなって
しまうんじゃないかって恐れるからです
さぁ次によく聞かれる質問も2つ目
尾っぽや子どもを置いていって大丈夫だったのか
気になる方
多いですね
一応っとにも一緒に行くって聞いたんですけれども
いやーインドに興味ないからって言われた述べまあ一人で行くことにしました
家事は大丈夫だったのか
我が家は普段から夫が料理を担当してます
夫のほうが残り物の活かし方も上手いし
味付けにもバラエティがあるんです
他の家事も問題なくできますので何も心配はありませんでした
この質問私たち囚われてるなぁって実感するんですよね
妻が育児も家事もするもの
もうそんな家庭ばかりじゃないですよね
もしこれが夫が3週間海外出張に行くって聞いたらどう思いますか
きっと私たち奥さんがゲームのことするのねと思って同じ質問しない気がするんです
でももう時代は変わってきています
私たちなんとなく世の中はこうあるべきっていう枠に当てはまるローとしていて実は
それが窮屈だって事に気付いてないんじゃないでしょうか
3歳の子供がいる母親なのに3週間も家を空けてもいいのか
3歳の子供が一人であれば大人1人で十分面倒が見られますし
夫は快く送り出してくれました
子供は寂しがらなかった
これは一理あります
でも工夫の余地もあります
私は行く先々で
メッセージビデオを撮って送ってました
pop からばそれを見て嬉しそうにこう手を振る
子供のムービーが送られてきました
あいつは自分勝手な奴だって周りから思われるのが嫌
この気持ちすごくよくわかります
私もかつてそうでした
結構ずっとそうでした
でもあると気がついたんです
楕円にも迷惑かけてないよね
私の価値観があってパートナーがいればパートナーの価値観があってそれがあっていて
他に迷惑をかけていないのであればそれでいいんじゃない
も知りたい人がいるなら言わせておけばいい
そういう風に思えるようになったんです
世間と違うことを恐れずにいたいそういうふうに今思っています
さあよく聞かれる質問シリーズの3つ目最後です
どうやって寒やクンブメーラん情報を得たのか
聞いなるかパ
ありがとうございます
私定番にあんまり興味がないんですね
なので facebook で詳しい人オススメ教えてくださいって聞きました
結構皆さんからいろんな情報が集まりました
有名な祝っていうお祭りについても聞きました
色水を掛け合うお祭りなんですけれども
セクハラを受けずにホーリーが楽しめる場所はどこか
私はやりたいことはすごい一生懸命やるんですけれどもやりたくないことは絶対やら
ない
そう思えるようになってきたんです
セクハラを受けるのは絶対に嫌でした
結果として
見つけられませんでした
その代わりマハーしばらー treat you
シヴァ神の祀るお祭りがあるよっていうことを教えてくれた人がいました
て調べてみるとライナーな情報ばっかりではあったんですけれども
ルーは出てくるはクンブメーラは出てくるわああこれは何かとんでもないことが行われ
ている違いないと思いました
不満じゃなかった
全然
だって情報ソースはマイナーだったけれどもしっかりしたものたとえばインド政府が
出しているものだったり
なによりも自分が本当がこれを行われているのかって
確かめたかったんです
インドに行くも怖くなかった
怖いと思いませんでした
なぜなら危険と言われている地域には絶対につかよらないし
雰囲気のあるい通りにも入りません
プロ遅くに一人で出歩いたりも絶対しません
話しててあこの人なんか信頼できないなぁと思ったらそれ以上絶対が辛くしません
これぐらい備えた上でもうし何か悪いことが起こったらそれは運が悪かったということ
で日本でも起こるかなというふうに思っています
私たち期待どおりに物事を運ぶことに
当たり前と盛りすぎてはないでしょうか
でも無難に無難を重ねてももう何には生きていけない時代だって
私たち薄々気づき始めてはいませんか
想定外のことが起こってもこれら人生の醍醐味だと思って楽しむ気持ちで生きていき
たいと思っています
さあ私は
怖くなかったって言いましたけれども今まで旅の中で怖いと思ったことがあります
それは何かというと南極に細長いチリっていう国があるんですがその南端にある
パタゴニアという地域まで行ったのに南極に行けないかもしれないって思った時後輩と
思いましたここまで来たのに
日本に帰る日が決まっているから通常のフェリーに乗ったら時間切れだと思って
強くなったんですけれども必死に調べました
そしたらチリの空軍が飛行機を飛ばしていることがわかってそれに振ってもらって無事
南極に行くことができました
冒頭に私は
結婚相手を探したいから
世界史をしたって言いました
でももうお分かりですね
本当は世界一周をやってみたかったから
理由はそれだけです
日本で全然モテなかったって言いました
今なら分かります
世間でこういう人が帯びそうだっていうことに当てはまるロ
そういう人を探すを探そうとしてたから見つからなかったんです
今は本当に大事な人を見つけることができました
あなたがやりたいと思っていることは何ですか
自分の好奇心に素直になって
周りと違うことを恐れずに
想定外の事も楽しむ気持ちでぜひ実現させてみてください
ありがとうございました
[拍手]